that's not the plan real 92 3 with the
BET Awards
Jeezy Stockton's finest Hayden baby 209
is here okay I gotta ask you because I
love Stockton hip-hop okay I love this
guy he he was uh he was on our Show when
he had like I don't know 500 followers
he just said something crazy what made
you sign Haiti baby man I shout out to
Superstar Trey uh CT new worlds A and R
he kept bringing his music to the studio
he brought it like two days straight
right and um brought videos and
everything in the last one he brought
was uh never seen and and I I heard it I
saw it I said yo he got it he got it
let's let's sit down with him and talk
so we flew out here uh he met us in La
uh we said I had dinner chopped it up
and and just figured it out you have a
track record with West Coast artist
being on CT and it ain't going well yeah
yeah shout out to YG at 211 early on
um for you man is this like a dream come
true because Jesus you know he's [__]
cheesy you know I mean we're talking
about ctes legendary [__] yeah it is a
dream this drink come true is a lot of
it I manifested though but not cheesy
right I feel like I needed something in
the back as an energy at times I feel
like giving up GG came around the
perfect time 100 man now it's crazy
because you just saw his viral freestyle
you never even saw it so I didn't sign
him because of that just know that
yeah if you saw me because that that's
his numbers but by the way but by the
way you know he signed the Def Jam right
as well so he signed the Def Jam CT and
BD shots out of Def Jam that's that's
big you know 100 uh Jeezy tell me about
the book adversity for sale adversity
for sales my new book is a motivational
Memoir you can get it anywhere books are
sold right now no hat on the cover no no
hat I love it I had to give him that uh
it's a motivational Memoir comes out
August 8th and you can pre-order it
right now anywhere books are sold that's
um Amazon Amazon Prime Audible The Whole
Nine I I go ahead all right last week
you went viral okay you talking about
them two dollar subs what year was you
eating two dollars this was like uh like
the 90s but this is where you know this
crazy thing I'm glad you said that
because everybody people are not getting
the message about saving the money and
what you had to do but they'd rather try
to find the cap in it right let me just
clarify some things it was in the 90s I
was living with my grandmother in a
small town in south Georgia the
population was 2200 the biggest job was
at factories okay it was our first
restaurant in the city you see what I'm
saying we didn't even have a McDonald's
yet we had a we had a Subway and a
Hardee's you get it you get a you get a
a foot long sub for five dollars right
right and you get a six inch sub with
chips and a drink for two dollars I mean
I missed out on that one right I wish
they'd bring that one back
how much it is now but you gotta
understand this was like when Subway
first came out right right you know what
I'm saying so I don't know what the I
ain't been in there lately so I don't
know what they cost and by the way I
used to get seafood and crab you feel
that's it Seafood crap no no seafood and
crab yeah uh Jeezy I I think you've been
a great example of how to evolve in this
game how to mature in this game because
obviously you're I mean you know you're
you're like the Trap goat it's like it's
like you Gucci and tip at any order you
know what I'm saying right
um I think you showed a great example of
how to get past issues in the streets
when you guys did the verses for sure I
had heard that you and Freddie ran into
each other at the airport and
everything's Copa static I know he's
kind of shown some resentment for some
of the things he said right but you guys
had to have you guys I mean you know
it's all about communication you know
what I'm saying and for me it's just
like you know is is is is different
because it's business it ain't like we
got into nothing in the street right you
feel what I'm saying so it's just
miscommunication you know what I mean
and so you know when you're able to just
chop it up without anybody else being
around and everybody's calm you get an
understanding you know I mean it wasn't
really nothing anyway you know what I'm
saying but it was just like all right
cool that's what's up I gotta ask you uh
how hip are you to Stockton as a whole
as far as the hip-hop scene because it's
got one of the most bubbling scenes in
all of America around this you know I've
been pretty familiar with a lot of the
stuff that was going on in the bay yeah
um it's like the base like I would say
like a little brother kind of stalker
right yeah yeah yeah and
um and for me
um seeing what Haiti was doing and just
the way they was moving he was you're
the first one really it's like you and
MB now when I think of Stockton yeah we
show the first one he definitely made me
pay more attention to it and I know he
gonna put Stockton on the map worldwide
I could see it already 100 man what do
you got coming well you're about to be
on my show tomorrow so we got a lot to
do tomorrow but what's on the way but I
gotta say it again so July 21st I got a
project coming on EP okay executive
produce yeah I dropped two singles
already none too crazy in Channel blue
that's going crazy right now in the
South for me um I got another single
dropping this Friday called your baby
mama ugly oh [__] yeah I'm I'm back I'm
back that's the one already hey Jizzy
last question thug motivation 101 or the
recession the recession whoa whoa all
right both classes
all right and saying those are your two
percent man and we get new music soon
absolutely there it is man Jesus